pfefferspray attacke im europapark rust
am donnerstagnachmittag ist es zu einer
reizgas attacke im europapark rust
gekommen
ein großaufgebot an einsatzkräften von
feuerwehr rettungsdienst und polizei ist
im einsatz
der auslöser mehrere junge männer hatten
eine auseinandersetzung in der lobby
eines hotels einer der männer versprühte
plötzlich pfefferspray
durch das reizgas was sich daraufhin in
der luft des hotels befand also im
geschlossenen raum das hat sich dort
verteilt wurden dann auch noch 25
weitere gäste also unbeteiligte in
mitleidenschaft gezogen leichtverletzt
wohlbemerkt warum es zu der
auseinandersetzung in der lobby kam ist
unbekannt gegen die männer wird wegen
schwerer körperverletzung ermittelt
[Musik]